this episode is sponsored by betterhelp
give online therapy a try at
betterhelp.com Whitney and get on your
way to being your best self which I
wasn't the last couple weeks dude last
week I told you guys that I took a month
off of therapy because I feel like I had
it
in the bag it was cured it was in the
bag you know I went to Austin the Wi-Fi
was shady and I was like I'm I feel like
I got this I'm pregnant I'm hormonal
what could go wrong I just had my first
session back
um I want to say four days ago and I am
finally back to being a functioning
human I immediately unfollowed seven
people on Instagram muted about 40
people I was following a lot of cake
people
like just people that make cakes oh not
the mysterious is it cake people oh no
not just girls with huge asses
I was just following a lot of toxic
people and when you're not when I'm not
talking to a therapist that always seems
like a good idea I went to the grocery
store immediately after I talked to this
therapist I went to the grocery store I
stopped expecting food to magically just
appear in my fridge and be like well I
guess I have to eat Twix for dinner
I I I finally took my mother's ashes out
of a FedEx box
put them in a thing only spilled some of
them only a couple
they really don't give you a lot of
instructions on that but finally was
able to do that uh I've been getting off
the phone when I want to not when they
want to the whole thing is just a
miracle not going to therapy I feel like
it's like not putting on lotion you know
which you probably never put on lotion
you're a white man but
only if it's a real issue
only if your wife's out of town
it's like I feel like not wearing lotion
like not wearing it not you like you can
go a couple days by the fourth or fifth
day you're like why am I bleeding like
why am I in so much pain it's the same
thing with therapy you know you gotta go
you gotta do it
everybody's uh losing their minds please
I can't take your guys's drama anymore
it's also it's like not brushing your
teeth you know you can go a couple days
get away with it and then your teeth
feel like they're wearing sweaters it's
the same thing in your brain it builds
up like plaque brain crazy plaque right
the older I get the less I really want
to talk to my friends about my issues
because everyone I'm talking to a
therapists everyone in my life is a mess
okay everyone I used to call for advice
now is in like a throuple or they're
trying to get their kid in pageants or
something and I'm like I'm gonna just
talk to a pro if that's cool if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
for no additional charge let therapy be
your map with better help visit
betterhelp.com Whitney today and get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
health.com Whitney
I'm so glad that we're doing this I
definitely feel a little bit of pressure
but don't do not do not you were on my
podcast that one uh and you were great I
don't think I think that's aired yet
okay nice thank you I had a blast yeah I
did too okay good no don't worry we're
we're good together we're good together
it's also there's not a lot of people I
get star struck by oh my God now you're
making me uncomfortable good that's what
this podcast is all about we make guests
and the viewers frankly uncomfortable oh
good what's good but it's is are you
uncomfortable with that like I think
people try to play it cool I don't try
to play it cool if I get star struck by
someone if I make somebody Star Struck
my immediate first of all I'm like dude
come on it's just me and then I want to
say then I get nervous because there's
nowhere for me to go but down ah I don't
like that I'd rather I'd rather be I'm
putting you on a pedestal I'd rather
build myself up and have a realistic
impression of me I guess it's just for
me it's like I grew up in a home with a
lot of addiction a lot of alcoholism in
your show you know it was whether it was
celebrity rehab or what you were talking
about probably you were like the first
person I saw talking about addiction in
a way that helped me understand it in
any capacity so I have like an extra
okay so that that's actually a high
compliment for me because that's what I
was trying to do and and it's I'll tell
you the story how Celebrity Rehab happen
it's kind of interesting but I'm having
kind of a flashback first time I met you
was a Jim Jeffery's house that's right
when he was getting his citizenship and
we talked about codependency that's what
we talked about and so you you remember
that because I remember it but anyway so
Celebrity Rehab was I'm really fun at
parties guys I'm like hey do you want to
talk about codependence and we're gonna
get way to love addiction if you need to
it looks like a Sunday everyone's in the
pool in bikinis and I'm just like so I'm
on my fourth step just like do you talk
about yourself
is that do people really I mean are you
able to move through the world at all
like I I have a hard time moving through
the world without people expecting me to
be funny or being like tell me a joke or
yes do a video or whatever so it's not
so it depends you know we you and I both
live in lots of different worlds but
you're almost always funny I I have lots
of different worlds I living where I'm
doing different things and I make that
my next special title almost always
funny but I mean you also are as a or
out I'm either funny or really serious
right I kind of don't have anything
people know who you are is what I'm
saying and not just because you're funny
and they know your talents they know you
and and and I kind of feel like I I do
all these different things into people
what they want is typically me to solve
their problems right and it's you're
laughing at that why is that funny
it's just it's it there's very few
people where I'm like I can't imagine
how hard that is like I think people
look at stand-ups and they're like I
don't know how you do that but I love it
I love people to come up to me I love
being able to help but the problem is
people don't understand what they're
asking they they oftentimes
typically will have a question that well
they would either ask me things were
inappropriate and sort of back me
against the candy section at the
7-Eleven you know with stuff where I'm
thinking oh my God there's no going to
be no beginning middle and end of this
conversation like in an office you know
you come in here's the beginning you
tell me your thing we write it down
here's we come back next time we'll do
this thing when you're out in the world
there's no structure to the conversation
it could go forever sometimes it's
inappropriate stuff they want to hear
about their sexuality and things because
they remember Loveline more often it's
somebody sort of celebrity we have asked
uh who is asking a question where
literally if you could read the thought
bubble over my head it would be dude if
I had a team about a psychologist a
psychiatrist an internist of chemical
dependency counselor maybe a couple
other therapist types it would take all
of us nine years to help improve the
situations
they want an answer that that fixes it
now and that's a really interesting kind
of thing because
people expect information to fix their
emotional landscape you know and it just
doesn't I use information to motivate
people to go do the work and you know
how hard the work is and you got to do
it and do it regularly for a long time
to change the wiring and to change our
feeling States and stuff so no no there
we are uh all right well there goes my
first question which is fixed me and
I'm finding that I was talking to Tom
Papa about this last night so now that
I'm pregnant and kind of visible it is
wild the things people say to me and he
said he was like oh we realized when my
wife was pregnant that everything people
say to you is just admitting what they
feel there's certainly a lot of that
these days you're just a projection you
know I think that's a function of where
we are in terms of our character
construct in this country right now do
in general is someone that has seen you
know so much obviously um and we're
gonna get to the psychological stuff in
a second but that in general I find
whenever I'm judging someone else it's
usually because I see something in them
that bothers me that's the classic thing
it's like when you point one finger at
someone else you point through it
yourself but in general if I'm like she
just wants male attention I'm like
that's me no like it's the easiest way
to tell on yourself it's it's a common
thing and and I'm I'm and I'm not
labeling what you're describing except
to say that you know I wrote a book on
narcissism back in the 90s or 90s maybe
2000s now and um and I saw this all
coming I saw it I saw the narcissistic
turn we all have sort of had a
narcissistic turn in our character
structure yeah what's the difference
between narcissism self-obsession and
insecurity driven like I'm a piece of
shit in the center of the universe
so let's kind of break it down
insecurity anybody can feel insecure
right I mean it depends about what
you're doing with your life and how
you're functioning you know personally
and you have are you able to function
flexibly and the way you want to okay
but nobody's perfect right it's Whoever
has security so that that's a separate
thing in terms of self-preoccupation
that has lots of elements to it too
right people that are in pain it's hard
not to be self-obsessed if you're in
pain yeah right and that some of the
pain you may not be aware of maybe
trauma in the past maybe way in the back
but it's just driving that
self-preoccupation
narcissism is a specific construct I
think of it a few different ways uh you
know narcissistic disorder is one thing
I'm really not talking about
narcissistic personality disorder
because those are insufferable and they
aren't treatable and they're just
they're hard to be around there's a lot
of it these days but they're hard to be
here but all of us has these sort of
narcissistic traits now right and is
there kind of this this is sort of a you
know probably just a you know myth but
the idea of like you can tell a
sociopath if you yawn and they don't or
whatever like narcissists they'll never
admit they're a narcissist right I
remember going to a therapist and being
like am I a narcissist I mean I have
this job where all I do is talk about
myself and think about myself and she's
like narcissists normally don't come to
therapy and ask if they're narcissists
so narcissists could never entertain the
fact that they would be one whereas if
you said to me Whitney you might be a
narcissist I'd be like yeah I probably
am well you might have narcissistic
traits but to have a disorder like a
personality disorder people with
personality disorders don't perceive
anything in their life as relating to
what's going on internally in them it's
all out there lame blame whatever it's
all happening out there to me but it's
not because of me I I have no I've just
I think everything's my fault so
that's codependency which is a weirdly
kind of a I'm a codependent too right
and codependency is a weird sort of
inverse narcissism I hate myself I'm the
worst but it's still
yeah I'm wearing the party but also I
need to fix that person yeah they need
me and I'm saying everyone's broken
I need to fix that person implies they
all need my help right because I'm god
well it doesn't have to go all the way
there yeah interesting if you've gone
there yeah I just need like the exact
like you know when you're in a Coda
meeting and you're like oh yeah I'm
gonna change that person's childhood and
ancestral wiring and epigenetic
imprinting with my love like that's
delusional yeah and it but it is uh it's
compelling in ways that people aren't
aware of you it's for people who don't
know what we're talking about it's you
experience it as sort of a special
appreciation of other people's trauma
like I understand them deeply and I
could help them I just I can't but
really it's our pain that's being
mobilized we just can't tell the
difference between somebody else's pain
it's like we take care care take other
people the way we wish we were yeah it's
all to fix our own internal yeah right
and so my work in therapy which was a
long time I was in therapy a long time
was to try to figure out what I was
feeling I had an abusive mom and dad was
sort of narcissistic and uh so I never
got connected to my primary feeling
States so it was all fixing everybody
out here and keeping them okay so they
didn't my mom was very abusive and so
I'd show you an attack and if I can
control these other people I'll be safe
like because I never I can't predict
their moods and yeah you're just a child
naturally just starts doing that and you
start studying how to caretake the
narcissist and caretake the people that
can't you know caretake themselves so
that you're safe yeah and so and so on
one hand that becomes this great asset
because you become highly attuned to
other people right I mean you can shape
shaft you're a chameleon you can kind of
that that's an asset too but I always
thought the asset well what is the work
I do the asset was I could really feel
and appreciate and be empathic easily
the problem is that could be overtaken
by it sure and then I learned how to
make people laugh and cheer people up
which is what I had to do with the attic
so there it is or I would mistake what's
going on in you with something in me I
had to separate those feelings and and
I've gotten very good at that actually
thank to my therapist uh but back to the
back to the narcissist that's
fascinating codependents would make the
best doctor right and great nurses
nurses
yeah because they're selfless they're
taking care of people and they're for
anybody that has this in them it's a
great asset but don't rescue people yeah
when you rescue people you make them
dependent on Rescue yes you have not
helped them so it's like they're just
going to look for another rescuer or
they're going to keep building and
asking you for more and they don't grow
they don't get better the idea is to
give them the Dignity of their own
experience there's the insanity about
the homeless situation I could help
those people but you have to ask them to
do something right you have to say here
come with me and let's do some work
you're going to be there crutch their
ankle broken ankle's never going to heal
if you're going to keep giving them
their drugs they're going to die and
that's period that's you know people
believe out the fact that addiction is
Progressive illness Progressive
particularly opiate addiction it ends in
death period maybe that's what they want
the the maybe that's what the girl the
local governments want I worry it's so
Sinister to me that some of them just
sort of don't care if that's where it
goes so be it kind of thing wasn't it
Portland that did like a methadone
clinic I'm like maybe they just want to
kill them I mean they give them their
heroin now in San Francisco and it's
like look I could administer the heroin
to the patient they still will progress
they will still die
narcissism so narcissism at its core is
there's an is an injury right and uh it
makes it it it makes the child at some
point in their life feel small
insignificant shamed uh and they start
building a sense of themselves on top of
this very small inner core
of getting needs from their environment
as they need you to build themselves up
so they learn how to get from the
environment things to make them feel
bigger and better and more you know sort
of safe
unfortunately because of that they they
develop what's called a pseudo self it's
really not a it's not connected to their
primary affects there's no spontaneous
feeling States they can't because they
don't have feelings when your feelings
aren't really significant either and so
they're very prone to empathic failure
and can be abusive because they don't
really appreciate that you have feelings
necessarily in a certain States a lot of
us get that way these days okay guys
I know this is gonna be awkward I'm
pregnant and I'm horny
science
it's not just me it's me okay some
pregnant ladies wake up and puke I wake
up and jerk it I know that's crass but
it's biology I'm not going to be ashamed
and look it's I don't need some romantic
night with a whole thing you know it's
more like
checking a box literally uh you know
it's like there's something that happens
when you're pregnant you're like I'm
gonna murder someone if I don't have a
machine sucking on my nether regions
before I brush my teeth every morning I
don't know what it is okay I'm a big fan
of sex toys uh it look it used to be in
order to be satisfied sexually you had
to start texting with an ex or get on
some weird dating app or you'd have to
shave your toes put Sherry chapstick on
your undercarriage make a playlist with
Frank Ocean songs brush your hair
now all you have to do is open
a drawer and guys love sex toys too I
used to think they were intimidated by
them they love it guys using sex toys in
the bedroom it's like the new grilling
they love it fun love.com is now my
favorite website to get all things that
solve your horniness problem it's the
leading online retailer of sensual
Health wellness products offering a wide
array of Premier brands of toys lingerie
and accessories they've curated a
section of the highest quality products
offering everything from soft and sexy
to hot and spicy you'll be sure to find
what you're looking for if you're
looking for products to enhance arousal
sexy lingerie every toy imaginable
everything except
boyfriends girlfriends wedding rings
it's just about solving that biological
problem there is something to satisfy
any desire at funlove.com what are you
waiting for explore discover indulge and
make love Fun by visiting funlove.com
they just sent me this I'm very excited
for this is called the date night
special edition set hey girl this is
what date night looks like at this point
just this box to use on my box fun
love.com for a limited time my listeners
can save 25 off your first order by
entering code Whitney at checkout go to
fun
f-u-n-l-o-v-e.com use code Whitney at
checkout save 25 today that's fun
love.com code Whitney send make some fun
Love Today Is it true that um you can
kind of tell what someone
um like narcissists project the image
that their parents would have approved
of or that their parents would have
liked they can't do that so it can get
specific
athlete ever it's like oh your dad
wanted you to be a great actor sure and
that that certainly happens and back to
projection I I was listening to a French
psychoanalyst one day and he said
something simple but profound he says if
you're dealing with a narcissist and he
or she says you are what you hear is I
am I am I thought that was just a great
concept 100 yeah and I've just been
really like because you know we talked
about this and we'll get into I quit
smoking weed I got I got a little out of
control during the pandemic and um I had
trouble sleeping for a lot of my life
and so I'm like oh I'm smoking weed to
go to sleep instead of taking a Lunesta
which is bad for you and I'm not having
dreams and everyone I know is so
creative on it and maybe I you know need
to stop being so abstemious because
that's my addiction to control like the
Insidious nature of addiction I had
never had a substance thing you know it
was always I was in recovery to recover
from rest you know getting people sober
yeah her life was a drug addict even
though that's still a substance is the
internal drug cabinet of adrenaline and
cortisol and rescuing people and how do
I you know recreate my childhood
circumstance with maximum drama and only
surrounding myself with people that I
can't get sober you know just to be in a
constant state of hell and then all of a
sudden it's like I deserve this but
there but there's a there's a piece in
there that you left out which is that
you that you really can't get rid of as
a codependent is that you like addicts
alcoholics you like them you're
attracted to them and that's kind of why
I work with them I they're wonderful
that's the other thing is they're the
best
no no you don't tattoo
no silver people have cool tattoos I
need your ex-girlfriend's name on the
right above your ballsack that's my
thing and no one that wasn't
oh my God
I would stand in a guy that had no veins
in his arms because they had all
collapsed yes we've used them all yeah
and I was like that's hot
no but but you don't want to be around
them when they're using you need them to
be in sobriety for a long period of time
but I think there's probably something
about them genetically that there might
be something sick about though when I
was really dating hardcore addicts like
learning Spanish in order to fight with
drug dealers
so that you could fight with your
boyfriend's drug dealers and I think
there was something for me I was so
terrified of intimacy when you're in a
relationship with someone that's using
you're in something without being in
something they're not there you're in
intensity rather than an intimacy yeah
and they're confused and when you're Co
or low addict or sex addict you confuse
intensity and they can't reject you if
you have their cocaine
you know so then you're like managing
the person and you're caretaking the
person and fixing the person and you
feel like you have you're not a total
piece of shit because you're rescuing
something but in fact you're just
enabling and making the person sicker
it's misery I'm the lady in misery how
long ago was that relationship oh that
was I was like 23. okay like you know is
productivity and cooperation makes
dopamine right and just this false sense
of productivity yeah but it yes it's all
gets you high and all that too but but
it but it's it's our childhoods you know
it's it's our it's our attachments and
our attractions I grew up obsessing over
an addict how to make them happy it's
the only identity I had also the the
thing that we don't talk about much
certainly in our culture is where do
attractions come from like intense
attraction number one question literally
number one questions fetishes
attractions in the world that I live and
work in and probably some myself
personally uh it's trauma correct you
know I think for some reason our brain
is set up in such a way is when we have
childhood trauma we become a attracted
to people and circumstances that are
very much like the original trauma the
psychologist will go that we're trying
to master it solve it also I'm not even
sure that has any rational basis when
you have that trauma you release
adrenaline which turns into dopamine
right yeah but I think it creates some
wiring it creates some wiring in some
way that we just have to repeat repeat
repeat it must have had some
evolutionary purpose Advantage not for
us but maybe for the group watching us
do that yeah and fuck ourselves up or
something because it makes no
evolutionary sense in terms of the
individual but it is uncanny how people
get so attracted and they and what
happens if you really are if you notice
a pattern in your life where you are
attracted to a certain kind of person
and a person every time you you are you
start a relationship it ends up being
somebody who's abandoning or abusive or
whatever the thing is that you seem to
recreate it comes your comfort zone
that's the psychological aspect I'm not
sure there's a psychology again you just
do it yeah and these the the thing I
have to tell everybody is that you're
it's your body telling you something
right and when you feel lightning bolts
when you feel like oh I'm so attracted
to that person your body if that's your
pattern is a perfect instrument and even
if that guy or gal looks nothing like
and you making careful efforts to make
sure he doesn't have collapsed veins and
he's not a cocaine addict then not even
any tattoos he or she will oblige you
they will be the exact same person
because you're a perfect instrument your
trauma leaves a perfect sort of Mark on
you that gets recreated over and over
again it can be resolved right as we've
talked about it it takes time lots of
time trauma therapy codependency
recovery sex and love addiction recovery
these are all things you you'll always
still like I said you'll always like
them you got to be able to find people
that are not quite that attractive to
you they'll help I did a 10-month
attachment strategy course with this guy
George Haas is a podcast called I love
you keep going and sort of about you
figure out what your attachment style is
you know uh fearful avoidant preoccupied
and the way he describes it as Christmas
trees you walk into a party and someone
is your Christmas tree they just like
they light up they glow from across the
room there's some kind of it's across
the road that's how insane we are you
vibrate on a different frequency to this
person no no but is he talking about is
that healthy attachment too or just yeah
just the some I will the most
normal so to speak who's nobody but
normal people don't have that
let's say securely attacked they'll take
their time to develop them I have this
wound that's one side of the puzzle
piece you have this other side of the
puzzle piece Boom everybody else is
boring and basically it took me a long
time to realize like this guy's boring
this relationship is boring and boring
and uncomfortable boring and
uncomfortable number one it took me a
long time I would conflate boredom with
Serenity that's actually just Serenity
but I'm I'm really like I'm made in a
lab for that chaos that doesn't mean I
have to do it but it took me a long time
to go like I'm just bad at Serenity I
don't when things are calm when someone
you got your next stand-up should be
Whitney Cummings made in the lab
what is it these days um
um and uh in the Chinese spot and so um
you know it's kind of like when things
are Serene when someone's available when
someone's consistent when someone loves
me I start to get a little you get wacky
well because I'm like well what are you
hiding are you a Scientologist like
when's the other shoe going to drop I
start to kind of like feel like the damn
the dancing sword is yeah and it's very
it's a so and really it's just fear of
attachment fear of closeness and oddly
the person who's unavailable and chaotic
is more comfortable to me because I
don't have to fear being seen excuse me
being rejected because it's already just
yeah it's all you're just dealing with
the intensity at all not with the real
relationship totally and so even though
you will be that chaos is more
comfortable than intimacy and by the way
when it ends or he or she leaves
whatever you're still gonna feel
horrible maybe sometimes worse because
you're sort of re-traumatized it's all
over again there it is again so the idea
is like you know can a pizza for dinner
every night it's like yeah I would love
to go eat that cake but I'm not going to
I would love to talk to that guy but I
know how this ends you know where it
goes that's exactly you got to know that
clearly and then and then there's sort
of an intermediate Zone you can kind of
get into where you know maybe a
recovering addict for 10 years sober or
whatever you know you're taking some
risk with that but that's probably
somebody who could be close to you and
still has some of those qualities you
like whatever I mean you can have some
lightning bolt or a little Thunder in
the background yeah you just can't be
Thunderstruck yes yes and love addiction
is real it is it's really hard to
delineate the difference between ACA
codependence and the love addiction
thing correct but it really helped me to
just very simple definition of the
definition of addiction is like yeah it
first of all stops being fun you know
and you're not able to stop when you
want to and those toxic relationships
where you keep going back even though it
always hurts you're it doesn't it kind
of boil down to a gambling addiction too
well they're all very similar they all
kind of because you're like two weeks
ago we had a great night maybe tonight's
the night you're kind of like at the
craps table oh that's really interesting
yeah that that part where the the cycle
of abuse is going you know tonight's the
night it's gonna be good so there's also
the the way the abuser plays those
experiences is when you do get the
reunion it's so idealizing over the top
and intense and everything and then here
comes the abuse on the right side right
yeah let me ask can I just real quick is
gambling addiction something that is
from what I understand that's the
roughest or it is very tough and it's
sort of the clearest behavioral
addiction that has you know that a model
of addiction really fits it really fits
it and the interesting thing about it is
there's different kinds of gambling
addiction there are people that are
actually debtors and like losing they
don't like losing so much what they like
having their back against the wall they
don't feel alive unless they're unless
they're they're in trouble you know
they're losing they're out of money
they've deaded they've stole stuff
that's that's where they want to be
that's where they get high right there's
gambling addicts that like making money
I I had a friend that was a um a whale
manager in Vegas and he said he goes
I'll Court them I'll bring them in and
when they win a million dollars I know
they're going to lose everything in six
months I'm like you know that and you
still do it is it like me with a good
relationship oh my God I gotta ruin this
right right well they know the game they
get stuck in there he just knows how
gambling works and if you're in the
winning thing you can't take the win
you're not gonna win you're gonna lose
eventually you just and so so people get
high off winning which is not as common
as you might think and there are people
that dissociate when they gamble so the
people that do the slot machines and the
poker machines video machines I had a
guy that ran a friend of mine ran a uh
gambling lab where he'd put Pete why are
people up and said we were to University
Nevada Las Vegas and he said he had two
or three gambling addicts screen
gambling addicts again poker or or slot
machine who would actually go to the
casino in diapers because they would
dissociate so much they would just they
would pee themselves and stuff that is a
rock bottom if I've ever heard one when
you're checking out with the pens at
Costco that's when you need to take a
good hard luck to go check to go buy the
MGM yeah whoo yeah so there's lots of
difference which by the way I did go to
a Workaholics Anonymous meeting once and
everyone was late and we were all like a
good 45 minutes late uh most of us got
in trouble because it was you know it
was a lot of people in our business that
you know a lot of us recognize each
other and
um we kept saying to each other like I
love your work I was like I love your
work big fan and they're like you can't
say that in here because we're calling
like we're basically it's like it's like
being at an AAA meeting and being like
you are so hilarious drunk our boys more
than that it's like dude we did cry
together
was like so we were all just it was very
it was very awkward but there were
people that were addicted to like
scrapbooking who couldn't stop people
that would sneak out of their house at
two in the morning to go back to their
Boutique that they owned you know so
this kind of stuff gets going there was
a a one person's bottom line which is
bottom line is explained is like a thing
that a line you won't Cross or so so
there's there's Circle plans and bottom
lines and so the way behavioral
addictions are dealt with because a lot
of these behavioral addictions you have
to still do you have to eat you have to
have sex because you have to you have to
have sort of things that you just won't
do for a while and sometimes things move
in and out of that won't do category you
have things that are slippery and
dangerous you have to be careful about
your sponsor about and you have things
that are good at enhancing and so you
make a point of doing those things well
like a bottom line for Overeaters for
example I won't have Cheetos in the
house right they don't get to be in the
house at all right I mean just a bottom
line and a bottom line for a woman who
was a workaholic in that meeting said
when I have to pee I will get up and pee
and I I do that I'll be writing and I'll
be like okay I'll just one more page and
then I'll pee
no one gives you a check or a trophy
when you haven't peed and give yourself
a UTI but I know that I haven't gone
that far obviously but I you know if I
pee I'm gonna fall behind I have a
severe workaholic too severe Spirit
severe I am oh I was really bad but but
before I would but if you're saving
people's lives
it's like being it's like being an
exercise you know a uh bulimic exercise
bulimic because everyone reinforces what
you're doing so you're doing you're
looking great you're doing good okay oh
my God what are you doing nothing just
back to back to the thread but it's sort
of like if you get sober off workaholism
a lot of people probably will die
no pressure so thank you sorry
um but I'll tell you how fat I took it
um but the um there is a sociopathic
gambling addict too there are sociopaths
that are trying to manipulate with
gambling and those guys are really they
need the best poker players there
probably are and they but they often
kind of flirt with criminality too so
this sort of that are they single
wait who do you know any of them
yeah I've seen him have any good tats on
them I'm curious about fetishes um oh
yeah we talk about we don't really know
we don't know about the foot fetish
thing there's everything from toes look
like dicks to you know the theory that
you know if you're a little boy that was
crawling across something intense
happens and you felt it on something on
your genitals while you saw your mom be
barefoot doing the something we just
don't know about something intense you
experience also the foot the image of
the foot and certain sexual arousal
centers are very closely connected
anatomically yeah so some people
theorize It's actually an atomic I'm
like almost like a synesthesia yeah yeah
but with your dick but it's also like
it's just I it's it's why is it only men
why is it in defeat yeah it's always men
women don't I think women are like with
hands I'm like I'm into men's hands
interesting but that makes sense doesn't
it you want a man that has hands that
can carry things carry a baby
and they hold up the ballerinas by their
poses it's like Bally's wild It's gotta
go why what are we doing
um I got in trouble for that like you do
oh the ballet Community came for me
they're like this is the basis for all
dance like it was a joke you can't can't
but it's also if you are going your
addiction you're intentionally going out
of your way to misunderstand what you
know is a joke in order to justify being
offended being offended and being a
victim 100 you're addicted to
self-righteous indignation which is so
much today so much so disturbing I think
I think we're gonna look back and go
like oh we the same way that now like
our rehabs are opening up for cell
phones and social media and we're gonna
go like oh that was the self-righteous
indignation addiction from social media
and these people like we'll have
compassion for them ultimately
no I feel bad for the person that has to
go out of there that can't enjoy a joke
yes because they need so badly yes to be
mad yes I that to me is just like the
ultimate if you're addicted to crack or
so I'm like oh yeah there's a lot of
categories of that for me like somebody
wearing a mask outside a paper mask
especially that's your addiction what
did we do to you we've done something to
you I'm sorry you know I do feel so good
I think at this point if you're wearing
a mask in public you're just trying to
cover a herpes outbreak we know what
you're doing okay I know what you're
doing don't do this you just take a
Valtrex like an adult
um do you think however that that
people's addictions uh sex stuff is
getting more extreme because of porn or
has it always been extreme and I think
it's getting hard to say right because
it's always been so covert right I do
think it's getting more extreme because
of the internet and you're basically
your tolerance gets higher and higher
I've seen this crazy thing now I need to
yes yes and you know if you were into
women in high heels stepping on bugs or
something 40 years ago sure how much
satisfa where are you gonna find that
right but now they can just spend all
day you know amplifying that crazy
preoccupation right right do you um
think there's any iteration of porn
that's healthy
I I have a I have mixed feelings about
porn I I I I do feel those and there's
such a spectrum of it yeah there's
plenty that's fine right I I worry about
the people
performing at it because some you know
sometimes they're being exploited take
advantage of and they don't really know
what they're acting out and whatever but
that's up to them right right
um you'll be surprised how many laws I
had since doing the um with only fans TV
the roasts and stuff and
um I've had on a bunch of uh we'll get
to monetized if we say porn star at this
point what are we saying Porn Star
Cinema thespian adult cinema thespian
whatever I didn't know that they do drug
testing
before every shoot I mean a bunch of HIV
tests yeah better health care than
comedians
for sure yeah uh so you know they're
careful about what they're doing but but
they some of them are actually I think
are doing something that's fine they're
not hurting themselves but other ones
have a lot of trauma and stuff and
they're like I'm fine with it you know
the trauma people are gonna find them
fine I'm fine I just this is just what I
want to do you're just like okay just
you know why do you why are you so
disgusted why are you crying why are you
crying
you know whatever tattoo that says
breathe
but so so uh I remember back in the day
you know I was deep in the AIDS pandemic
epidemic and treating treating those men
and it was just the darkest saddest
there's so few people around that can
tell you that story about how profound
that was and back then you know when one
male partner would get HIV we'd tell the
other like you guys can mutually
masturbate watch porn together we'd
actually formally recommend this you
know uh so it had a therapeutic value at
one time
it's bringing to the present moment I
think if couples want to they get to
watch it together and stuff like that
fine people need to masturbate fine I
mean it's not it's it's not unhealthy
yeah it's when you're nine and getting
exposed to it or you're addicted to it
you can't stop I mean this is a problem
Dan mentz he's um written on a ton of
stuff he has this joke he does he's like
one-liners like Steven Wright one-liners
and he has this amazing joke he goes you
know like porn has changed so much like
you know it used to be I would wait
around for the Sears catalog to come and
then I would flip to the lingerie
section but now I can just go to
sears.com
we used to talk about how he would
masturbate to the the the the box cover
of the pool floaty you know there'd be a
woman
oh what the blue and yellow pool
floating and then he goes that that was
what I took home with me he was near the
construction of the Box just like this
is so well constructed but what you
don't appreciate as a male is once that
biology turns on it is I what it was God
thinking what was he thinking yeah
because it's so intense and so
overwhelming for the male and and I
think there's something that happens
between about 11 and 14 where it also
wires in preferences the things you see
that are so intense you become like
that's your thing is there a connection
between breastfeeding and Obsession baby
I'm not that maybe maybe not
um certainly there's you know people
I've certainly seen a pattern in men
that are breastfed well into childhood
there seems to be like an open like
that's what I like because you're in a
relationship with your mom why are you
breastfeeding till five yeah you're with
your kid now but I do know when I got my
sex robot built the sex robot Factor
tell me more that is a gift
in my uh fourth special I had a section
I remember yes yes I'll show it to you I
did see it I saw it I'll show uh you
what I ended up making but they had this
wall of nipples uh that men could pick
which nipples they wanted the most
popular was dark and large like a large
area a large Oreo large nipple and dark
nipple which is when you're pregnant
your nipples get darker when you're
breastfeeding so there is that's
interesting very interesting yeah and
something really promising or exciting
or you know everyone was like sex robots
they're bad I got all this information
that was so heartening the biggest
complaint people have about the sex
robots and the sex dolls right now is
that they're too thin and they're too
skinny but a lot of people that purchase
them are handicapped you know they're
charged they're hard to carry around so
they want bigger ones they want ones
with bigger thighs bigger asses bigger
arms but they're just too cumbersome to
carry around interesting yeah men they
don't like super thin what they request
in private is actually really promising
no we like we like
men are all over the place but but a lot
of that gets wired in 12 to 14 and it's
wired in by images they see and uh I
think Playboy had a big effect on a lot
of men it seems like a lot of oh by the
way my OB I'm you know because I'm a
comic I'm always like what are the
latest trends like what's going on like
what are you hearing what are the latest
like STDs like whatever and she was
she's so amazing she just tells me
everything she goes um well a lot of
women are actually asking for plugs
because they had lasered off their uh
pubes and now pubes are back in oh my
God that's one like if you tell me
merkins are back that is wild because
everyone lasered myself included and now
pubes are kind of back so when you laser
your pubes you laser everything you
laser everything and the way that I did
it I did like seven or eight sessions
and it comes back it's more it's like
Smithers hairs it's not fully cut it
comes it's like yeah like chemo energy
big chemo energy
it's like leprosy pussy so you kind of
have to like shave it a little bit he's
laughing but he's under his ground
emailing Human Resources
um and so yeah it you laser everything
and you know for the most part it
doesn't grow back if you did it the way
I did it yeah I got a coupon and went
harder I remember when I first saw that
or heard about I didn't see it so much
but I heard about the transformation
from the gynecologist about the nude
vagina and I was like what that's like a
little kid it is it is kind of people
but then you get like then it's a thing
then you're expecting that yeah it's
it's weird how things well because
that's kind of what was in porn but now
guys can see that all the time in porn
and there's something really sort of
exotic or something intensity again yeah
about seeing cubes again because I think
guys that guys that like the generation
before grew up looking at pubes in
Playboy so by the time they got out in
the world and they saw bald they were
like what yeah but now they grow up
seeing bald first yeah yeah you know and
then so to see pubes is like you're
right exotic that's so fast so I don't
know him was just so fucked up
you're so fucked up I mean really that
is just the best way to put it as
someone that knows as much about this as
you it's like we're fucked up man I love
them I do I'm fascinated by them The
Human Experience is the is my entire
being I've invested in it and I and I
love it we are fucked up yeah I mean
we're also wired for a civilization that
doesn't exist anymore we're wired for
very different circumstances you know so
we kind of have all these obsolete
survival mechanisms and yeah yeah
instincts yes but I I the and my yes but
is so let's be aware of let's not
pretend they're not there and manage
them manage them so they work for you
but don't pretend we want to pretend
these things aren't there or haven't
come through biological history they're
there and we can we work with them
they're fine there is a big trend of men
that are abstaining from masturbating
yes there's always wise bath people yeah
that would help but there's all this
there's all sort of in-cell stuff all
over the place now but is that techno
because it's I know a couple guys that
they don't watch born and they don't
jerk off and I'm like that feels like
another addiction to control or another
thing and then now you're gonna have to
be more promiscuous or it feels
something's up right but after a while
does it start to be less intense yes it
does how long does it take if you're
gonna kind of if you want to stop
because if you do have a masturbation
addiction or sex addiction you do have
to go fully
fully know as Adam says cold jerky
[Laughter]
cold turkey If You're Gonna Go cold
jerky how long
to stop wanting to shoot up a school
it's it's very as I think about it
interestingly it's it's very similar to
what it's in my head is the the graph on
testosterone which starts to fall if you
restrain yourself from sexual activity
and that helps but in in reality it also
runs a pattern similar to how any
addiction settles down takes about six
months and it may be three to four to
start to be like okay stop craving it
yeah but uh is some of that I'm sure is
testosterone falling also but it's not
Optimal Health either right because your
body wants testosterone you can you can
deplete your testosterone by jerking off
too much yeah and you can it can fall
when you don't have enough sexual
activity
and now here's a little insight into one
of my therapy sessions with a better
health counselor hey Sue Jo M.A is a
licensed marriage and family therapist
with clinical focus and interest in
Asian American mental Wellness anxiety
and stress management relationship and
family Dynamics and Trauma relief Jesu
is the current head of clinical
operations at better help the world's
largest online therapy service where she
empowers other therapists and being
successful at bringing their skills
online asujo's input is General
psychological information based on
research and clinical experience it's
intended to be General and informational
in nature does not represent or indicate
an established clinical or professional
relationship with those inquiring for
guidance also just because you might
have heard something on the show that
sounds similar to what you're
experiencing beware of self-diagnosis
diagnosis is not required to find relief
and you'll want to find a qualified
professional to assess and explore
diagnosis if that's important to you if
you or your partner in a crisis and
uncertain of whether you can maintain
safety reach out for support crisis
hotlines local authorities have a safety
plan that can be done with a therapist
too
when I think about forgiveness I think a
lot of people focus so much on the other
person like how can I forgive them and
move on a lot of times people aren't
really thinking about how they can
forgive themselves or whatever was
involved in this thing
um it's it's not being able to let go of
your perceived contribution to this
issue
um you mentioned shame earlier and shame
is this feeling that comes when we think
we did something bad not because of like
an error that day but because we are bad
and when you really internalize this
feeling and this idea that you are a bad
person then everything that you do
everything that you respond with it's
because you're this evil unlovable
unworthy being that isn't worth
um love and care and forgiveness so when
somebody's unable to forgive themselves
really
um and and place compassion and Grace
and mercy on self
it's very very difficult to move forward
and do anything and be productive and
healthy and how can you exude
loving-kindness to others and and put
that out into the universe when you feel
so terrible about who you are
that's so hard to like
delineate I it took me so long to
realize when I'm walking down the street
like oh this guy like oh this guy excuse
me like
I I was so um anesthetizing Myself by
judging other people I didn't realize
the root was self-loathing because
ultimately I was the one that was you
know hurting myself
these are people that they didn't even
know I was saying this or thinking this
about them they were just moving through
the world and I'm and I'm sort of like
death by a Thousand Cuts of judging
strangers of this guy and this girl and
uh this this girl taking a selfie in
front of a wall with wings like uh what
a shallow like I just like I'm poisoning
myself and this is how much do I hate
myself that I believe that this is the
experience I deserve that this is the
inner monologue that I've chosen to
curate for myself just moving through
the World Angry judgy uh skeptical you
know I remember a girlfriend of mine
when I was struggling with
eating issues and was restricting and
trying to do as few calories as possible
these you know they were these like diet
sodas I would drink these you know
gross like fat free can't uh potato
chips with a less straw I don't know if
you remember that phase where they on
the bag it literally said
these chips inhibit the absorption of
vitamin D and may cause like anal
bleeding I mean it was like these were
the you know what I was eating as food I
gotta be skinny you know I thought it
gotta be thin that'll fix it that'll
make my mom stop drinking and um
I remember a girlfriend of mine came
over Jenny Goodwin told the story uh
before it's in my book and she opened my
Cabinets To Go get a snack and she just
gasped like and she just said um it's so
hard to look at this because this is
what
you think you deserve this is what you
think of yourself and she just kind of
said it and it like it didn't occur to
me that you know what I was feeding
myself was a reflection of what I
thought I deserved and the thoughts that
I chose or allowed were what I believed
I deserved to have to think all day so
it was a little bit of a you know you
know mind Bend to have to go there
because you know I also realized that I
sort of thrived on self-righteous in the
nation because I was so insecure my
self-esteem was so low that I had to
move through the world and judge people
oh look at those pants like wow look at
her she has to show her butt to get
attention and she like I had to judge
people in order to make myself feel good
about myself and it it was it took a
second and I think you know what would
you say about people who realized that
just had a big Epiphany because we just
had that exchange on this podcast of how
to build self-esteem because you see on
Instagram love yourself
like you put you know you can see that
adage but it's like how you know
something that's helped me was um a
therapist told me once in order to build
self-esteem you have to engage in
esteemable actions
it's not a passive sort of thing you
know just sit around and self-esteem
comes to you because you hope for it you
know so little things taking your
neighbor's trash out saying good morning
to someone you know uh you know being of
service in some way volunteering you
know calling a friend checking on them
without spending the whole conversation
talking about your problems you know a
friend of yours that's a new mom
bringing her food some you know
something that is just like is an
esteemable action that's how you build
pride and self-esteem does that feel
right have I been conned
um that sounds lovely to me actually and
and uh there's a lot of research that
shows practicing altruism does a lot for
our self-esteem our sense of value our
sense of
um self-efficacy which is the belief
that I can do what I put my mind to
um I want to add to that doing
esteemable things and practicing
altruism which of course is acts of
kindness with no expectation of
something in return is treating yourself
like somebody that you love even if you
don't feel that way right now it's not a
passive thing people ask me all the time
how am I supposed to love myself like
you said like I see all the stuff out
there all the wellness products and
various ways that people can get into
this
um you know mentality of
really really loving themselves but for
a lot of people that feels unattainable
because they don't feel that so it's
like somewhere to start is to just treat
yourself like somebody you love
um somebody you love you would make sure
shake it till you make it yeah it's
behavioral activation you do the
behaviors and your Insight will soon
follow if you stick to it you know if if
you love somebody you want to make sure
that what they're consuming whether
that's food or anything else media is
nutritious for them and fulfills the
needs of their individual system right
so it's like if you love somebody you're
sure not gonna always have them eat
stuff that's not very healthy because
you have their best interest in mind so
same thing for yourself
I'm sure you're seeing a rise in
polyamory yes is this something you
believe is uh a way to justify addictive
behavior a way a trauma response cool
and long overdue something that's a
slippery slope
everything except cool and long overdue
I don't know anyone that is polyamorous
whose life isn't a mess that's correct
there there are armies of professionals
armies just trying to help two people
function in a relationship you bring a
third in it is exponentially more
difficult it's two people that aren't
going to text you back the next day and
it's a way of avoiding intimacy it's way
back to have sexual compulsions or
whatever and and it works for some
people right it we're I'm not taking I
don't judge they can do whatever the
hell they want it's just I've never
first grade for galane right I've never
seen it work long term never I've seen
it work for a while and sometimes quite
a while you know do you know Jason Ellis
well okay so you know he and his wife
they were notoriously polyamorous
whatever they were doing their thing and
and I would I watched them study them
I'm like well here too that it really
these these are the two finally I found
a couple for him it works and now
they're getting divorced yep and she is
not into it it feels like the beginning
if you've been in a long relationship
have you seen that it is like the
beginning of the end
when you bring that when you it's never
get makes things better when you bring
other people in but the most significant
and common thing is it triggers feelings
you can't predict you can't anticipate
whether it's attachment to the other
person or I'm gay or I I I'm jealous
whatever it is you don't you don't know
and by the way then people go to Great
Lengths to deny it and suppress it and
then it comes it really comes out yeah
so I'm like just cheat on me like a
normal person well like don't pretend
like this is going to be a consensual
like Mormon dream and usually
I'm sorry like what are you saying
don't let me find out about it but
usually one person is driving it and the
other people are sort of coerced into it
that's what I know most yeah yeah one
person's cheating and one person
suicidal yeah and so the way they manage
it to stay in the relationship is okay
okay well we'll just open it up and do
whatever and I said right
yeah okay I'm glad we're on the same
page about that well it's just
practically the truth if I if we're if I
saw something different clinically yeah
totally I haven't seen someone thriving
in it yeah I haven't seen it I wish we I
wish it was like that would be fun yeah
like trust me if this could work
absolutely but I mean your wife's been
doing it for years maybe we don't know
we have to bring her in here but but
it's but now we're you know I'm home
much much more by the way
so but but it is something that we're
into work I would I'd be fully endorsing
I would be right with nothing I'm not in
Judgment of I don't object to it I feel
like you've seen addictive behavior for
so long yeah you know and I think that
to me polyamory feels like uh the
addictions way of tricking you into
thinking you're doing something
Progressive or healthy or whatever or
codependency or whatever it's all the
same stuff and and on that same line of
thinking and by the way intimacy
disorder under underneath it so you
don't have to be Intimates yes but it's
like I'm not going to stick to this
socially constructed idea of monogamy oh
my god when people start espousing these
sort of
rationalized bullshit
because they they have the addiction the
disease has managed to you know it's a
disease that tells you you don't have a
disease has managed to trick you into
thinking you're doing something forward
thinking and I you know we talked about
um uh off camera a little bit which I
you know want to make sure I talk about
on camera as well and on my shit of that
also happened to me with uh cannabis and
micro dosing mushrooms and probably I'm
sure in the 50s they were like martinis
it's like the three Martini lunch it's
good for your creativity I'm sure every
addiction was justified in some way well
and and but you but it has a new sort of
cloak which is it's it's it's
therapeutic or or it's going to enhance
your life and your view of reality and
your experience of things you're gonna
be more open emotionally and the reality
is the problem is there's a real basis
to it which is yeah probably we will
have that way of using these things one
day not now yeah we have no idea what
we're doing and so the potential for
harm is always present when you don't
know what you're doing when you use a
chemical that affects this thing this is
a very delicate instrument but it comes
from the earth and it's a mushroom it
wouldn't want Lake Amanita falloidy
sometimes see how long you survive it's
right off the forest floor it looks like
it looks like uh Alice In Wonderland's
mushroom you'll you take a bite of that
you'll be dead in 10 minutes but it
wouldn't want me to have a psychotic
break it's a plant we're the same and
speaking to me yeah so so one day we'll
have we'll kind of know who where how
risk I've seen so many adverse
consequences now from hallucinogens of
all types micro dosing mushrooms for
example using it whatever I mean I've
just seen so much stuff happen now and
then my new do is concern is the THC is
so powerful it's that it's just we it's
now things that I really doubted THC was
associated with I'm just seeing it all
the time in terms of addiction and
manias and psychotic episodes I I really
doubted that it really I just thought it
sort of maybe brought out that and
somebody it's causing it yep so what
happened to me in uh January when I was
micro dosing mushrooms because
everyone's like this is going to help
you get through your grief and it's
going to help you be creative and
forgive everybody and whatever and I was
doing micro dosing mushrooms in
chocolate bars like a couple nibbles a
day and then I was smoking THC to uh at
night to sleep but you know it's amazing
how you do it at 11 to go to sleep and
the next week it's 10 and the next week
you're like it's 6 30. should we it just
keeps moving up and moving up and you
know I'm not driving anymore today so
it's 11 30 you know and so it kind of
starts creeping up on you and then of
course you start losing count and then
the mushrooms are going going but it's
you know this is good for your creator
they start talking to each other and
working together and colluding against
you yeah and then I'm trying to find
Shelly miscavige
you made me understand that I had a
manic episode because you told me in a
parking lot in Culver City you were like
having a manic episode it makes you feel
like no one's listening to you well that
the the Mania associated with THC that
is a very characteristic symptom where
the all and I've seen a lot of mania
from THC and people who didn't have
bipolar disorder before and they'll
always in their sort of inflated state
where you're not listening you're not
listening you don't hear me there's a
lot of that which has caught my
attention because that's not normally
what I hear from patients in Mania they
just go on about their thing yeah they
don't worry about whether you're
listening or not and so but THC seems to
do something specific that way and the
good news is hey if it's a THC induced
Mania it's not really bipolar disorder
it's going to get better and you're
gonna be fine you know that's the good
news we think anyway it seems like that
and I think also the you know I don't
know exactly you know the mechanism
obviously for how the mushrooms work but
I think a lot of people do it to be
maybe more compassionate or to be more
forgiving of people as a you know a
codependent me having more compassion
that's not so good
for yourself I was getting I'm like it
put my trying to rescue people trying to
fix people into overdrive
Scientology and go after them Saudi just
put money into into this television
network we gotta stop I mean I'm like TR
I'm like there's the Cleveland Flint
Michigan we're getting clean well I mean
this is all stuff people should care
about but when you start thinking I'm
gonna be the person that's going to so
isn't that interesting we started this
conversation talking about the sort of
the the the narcissistic component of
codependency it's very giving it's very
caring it's very empathic but it's me uh
and then if that becomes grandiose which
is what Mania does mania makes things
grandiose now it's all about me good
Mama to save everybody yep wild no one
else cares you're not listening you're
not listening no one's listening no
you're not listening but my computer is
and my phone is and my ring cameras
they're listening well that's what it
gets it gets gets going yeah you're
really you're going I'm so glad you're
better
I'm so glad we were not podcasting at
that time
but it was I mean it just it happens so
quick and I think you know my biggest
mistake if if cannabis works for you
great work till it doesn't if you know
mushrooms works for you great yeah we
haven't we're not judging open relations
we're not Jenny camping I'm doing it
every day also if you're doing this
twice a year at Burning Man Coachella
fine whatever some people it's looks
like clearly some people they're they're
soup's fine you know stupid is worked
for him for a long time is fine but his
best friend is Martha Stewart I mean
it's there's definitely have you met Don
Magic Juan
really stoned you're all of a sudden the
people close closest to you are very
bizarre character
the fact that his best friend's Martha
Stewart it's like that's a little wild
it's a big swing
yeah Snoop is the best and um but I
found myself doing it to check out not
to check in my intention wasn't I'm
gonna be great but how can anything of
an intoxicant be other than that now I'm
saying that glibly I know the people who
are doing ketamine you know guided
therapies and people are doing
hallucinogen therapies of various types
and for sure MDMA and complex trauma has
a role I mean I'm not saying these
things don't have a role but
you know the the really hard work is
getting your brain to do what it's
beginning I was trying to take a
shortcut yeah no shortcuts I have you
ever done EMDR or anything like that
speaking shortcuts yes does that work
for you it was miraculous yeah I'm
wondering if I that you probably went to
the therapist that I sent everybody to I
think probably the the VA or the VA the
um yeah works with vets
no I'm thinking of somebody works with a
lot of drug addicts and codependents and
stuff okay uh she's amazing no I mean I
would love to I would love to do it
again I did it on one specific memory
and realized no no it's something you
got to kind of like keep going yeah a
little bit with
um but but in terms of shortcuts there
is one shortcut we have discovered that
doesn't involve
altering your brain involves just using
the internal mechanisms that are
available to access things to integrate
stuff to get things back online and
that's just reprogramming and
desensitization yeah EMDR yeah that's it
shortcut
um and so okay I want to get into a
couple health things and I want to get
into all the work you're doing I've
listened to the last like seven episodes
of your podcast been binging it of
talking about that uh I think it's not
ask Dr Drew I think it's a doctor too
the streaming show I want to that's been
a very interesting project I'm so
excited to talk about this but we're not
we're gonna call the vaccine let's call
it the dopamine the dopamine we don't
even talk about any of that because I
just I have talked to people that have
been canceled and have interesting ideas
and people that were extraordinary
professionals with with decorated
careers I thought well I should talk to
see what they've got to say I've learned
quite a bit yes and some of them and I
don't agree with it so much some of the
stuff they're saying like I don't know
but I really believe that
there's a fundamental problem right now
where there's a group of people that
think the way to deal with people that
tend towards paranoia or conspiratorial
thinking is to hide more information
yeah to hide everything it's the
opposite I worked in a psychiatric
hospital for 35 years the way you deal
with any paranoia in a normal person or
in a paranoid person fresh air yes don't
don't withhold anything just let them
have and let reason kind of settle in
let them settle down with whatever it is
they're getting excited about they'll
get back towards reality if you give
them all the information so that's been
that project of that project well to me
it's like I want to get to that in a
second I want to go through just like a
couple bullet points but you know it's
interesting because like when all that
happened I got the Johnson Johnson right
off the bat I got it assuming there
would be side effects any kind of Pharma
I assume there will be side effects
anything for me to do with viruses so I
get destroyed that's my life right and
so yep so I immediately got so do you
not want to talk about this on this
platform because it's not okay because
it's more I just want to commend your
bravery and asking questions and pushing
through because so many doctors won't
and can't and you're so weird to me it's
the opposite of what we've been trained
to do and I think the left used to be
the party of question everything
questions my whole career level I was
fighting the right they wanted to they
were calling the morning after pill an
abortion pill they didn't want the HPV
vaccine because it made sex easy for
adolescents and uh like these are these
are health questions you don't even
understand what you're talking about and
then all of a sudden the left now once
made quiet yeah it's the weirdest thing
and it's like who imagine okay whether
your form whether you forget against
them I don't have enough information to
no I'm going to defer to doctors on to
fact check whatever he's saying but the
fact that people like well he doesn't
know what he's talking about I'm like
and you do and by the way the actor on
the CW right what the f what is
happening what is happening that people
learned how to pronounce a medication
yesterday and today have opinions about
how it should be deployed if someone is
anti-corruption let's listen if someone
is saying I've been suing if someone's
been suing Monsanto if someone's saying
I'm gonna go in and get like like go
after all these agencies I'm gonna make
it so big Pharma cannot advertise on our
TV stations why aren't you going okay
even if half of what this guy says is
wrong yeah the other half is still
better than the 100 everybody else's
side I completely agree with you and I
interviewed him a couple times I I asked
Dr Drew and and he was I was very
interested in what he had to say and he
was just saying I just I just want there
to be more better studies that's all I
want better and then you guys want
Marianne Williamson I'm sorry I'm sure
she's lovely they're like you want the
lady that wrote books about God which is
good for you but God is where the facts
are like I'm so you know so to me I'm
kind of just like at a place where you
know I mean I think a lot of people
think of me as being very left and I I
probably used to all or Progressive
whatever that means but the left move so
far yeah yeah I feel like I'm just in
the middle going hold on hold on hold on
I know a lot of things but I I'm not
gonna
um be in uh
supportive big far I'm not going to
default to Big Pharma
they want the best for us is the capture
of people in Regulatory Agencies
magically showing up as Executives in
Pharma companies back and forth what is
that owning the medical journals and you
know owning the airwaves so we are
there's two countries where
pharmaceutical companies are allowed to
advertise on television here and I think
New Zealand whatever so the fact that
he's saying I want to make it so the big
Pharma can't advertise on television
that alone is is enough no one else will
even say that no one else will even say
it which is so shady to me but I guess
again I got the Johnson Johnson the
Johnson Johnson was pulled almost
immediately so so I'll tell you my story
with I took Johnson Johnson too I took
it because I didn't want to take two
vaccines because I thought I have
reactions to vaccines I'm crazy so I
don't want to do this I've lost animals
to too many at once and you know we're
animals yeah and
the next day they withdraw it after I
took it the next day and I work up the
next day with a spontaneous black eye
full black eye which is the presenting
feature of the transverse sinus
thrombosis which is the dreaded
complication of the of the That vaccine
and I thought looking in the mirror
going oh shit I'm going to be the only
male to get TTP from
from this vaccine and it sort of passed
and I was sick of shit and stuff but it
did because it was like most of the side
effects that happened right away or the
issues injuries were women reporting and
you know I'm Dave Chappelle used to do
this amazing joke about he goes um you
know uh eight men in San Francisco were
raped by a serial rapist and if eight
men came forward that means there were
hundreds
so when old women were coming forward
with their injury I'm like I'm sure men
have stuff but they're just like I'm
fine I'm about to go to the doctor you
know yeah yeah that's true but if it's
that pronounced how do you what I didn't
go to the doctor yeah
I'm not so here we go and so then it was
like Johnson Johnson pulled their side
effects three months later moderna
Pfizer comes out and I was like well
this one's fine it's like well how could
the one that was made in six months that
came out three months later these other
ones are gonna be perfect no to meet
when I take antibiotics I know there's
going to be side effects right I know
it's gonna destroy my gut and all things
have risk reward we weren't allowed to
talk about risk reward that's the most
astonishing thing in the world to me
everything I do with a patient I have to
evaluate is the risk worth it is the
reward worth the risk and and we were
forbidden from doing that that's not the
anathema medicine and I'm at the point
now where you know I I vax and boosted
all my elderly patients and I think they
derive significant benefit from it and
I've seen almost no side effect because
they if they catch it it's serious
business and by the way I have complex
medical patients I care for now I've had
people with you know tuberculosis and
liver failure and and get coveted and
I'm like oh shit I can't use Paxil van I
can't do this I can't do that but
they've been vaccinated I'm going to
ride this one out with them and see how
it goes it's worked you know it's not
you know a 29 year old who's getting
gonna have a cold why do I want to put
any risk in that person any expose them
to anything the virus is a nothing for
them so this is hard for me to
understand I think it's interesting and
I don't know what this would be called
um you know know herd mentality you know
whatever it is but I do think there are
certain things that are so big our
brains Can't Wrap our head around it and
we'd rather it
um we'd rather pretend it's not
happening some kind of mass denial like
you know school shootings I remember
when Newtown happened I was at a job
people were sobbing they didn't have
kids people that didn't even have
children the people that had kids we
sent home for the day it was like a
morning holiday and the whole rest of
the week everyone was somber and black
we were it's a comedy show we weren't
really making jokes
um now you see a school shooting and you
kind of keep going you know I think that
because most people have asked their
kids most people the idea of vaccines
being bad is just too much to take on
and our brain has to just shut down like
is there some kind of self-preservation
psychosis there is that mass formation
psychosis thing that a guy named
Mirlo Juiced I think it is first
described and then the Desmet forget
Desmond's last name just look up Desmond
Mass formation and it doesn't forget his
last name but these guys are you know
serious social psychologists serious
mental health professionals who have
been studying this stuff for years and
there's and they're looking at this and
going well here it is it's happening
right now everybody we've been telling
you people do this here it is and
they're like fuck you you know what
you're talking about it's like no no
listen to it let's let's work with this
I can't take this on yeah it's like when
um a couple weeks ago people were like
we just found out plants have feelings
I'm like can't take it on I can't do it
dancers no they don't I was in France
two weeks ago we I was at a Vineyard
where they were playing music for The
Grapes
I swear to God they do listen to me
they do they make music they listen to
me it's just like it's like when I tell
people you know the end of every episode
I don't say don't ride elephants and
when I you know people ask is it abusive
to ride elephants and it's like you tell
them like I can't take this on because I
definitely took my kids to Barnum and
Bailey I definitely have ridden an
elephant before I'm going to Thailand in
two months can't take this on yeah it's
too it's we're at our limit or something
you know because so to me the idea that
any party would think that big Pharma
has your best interest in mind is so
wild to me it's like I was on
antidepressants knowing okay this might
help me you know be a little less blue
but I know that I'm gonna lose my sex
drive and I'm gonna be tired and I'm
gonna have a dry mouth and all these
things but this is the one thing we've
decided there's just there's no way
there could be any side effects they're
too scared or I I don't know the
pandemic just this like our amygdala
just going off our frontal lobes just
went offline why you know why push so
hard just think about it we're pushing
so hard and how would you know doctors
are still trying to figure this out
there's not enough data for you guys to
even put it all together and we're
pushing populations who have like no
risk from the illness why are we pushing
them so hard I don't understand if
somebody could explain that to me maybe
I would understand but it just seems odd
to me and it feels bureaucratic it feels
arbitrary
uh and it does not feel like medicine at
all it's the opposite of medicine and
tribal well I guess this is the first
time there's been some kind of obviously
pandemic and medicine with social media
where people are weighing in and have no
business right your travel exactly like
if you if you dare question it you're
not in the tribe yeah and the idea of my
things happy to be wrong can I ask some
questions so it's like I'm about to have
a kid yeah and I'm afraid to say hey
I'm gonna fax my kid
but the hep C vaccine comes from gay sex
not planning on sending my kid to a
Catholic school so I don't know how
they'd have that you know and I guess
dirty needles
at at a year is that the time to get it
or do we do this at 10 do we do this at
15 I don't know the answer but I feel
like I can't even ask the the oddest
thing in the world to me now is that
somehow the public has come to believe
that the FDA the World Health
Organization and the CDC is determines
how doctors practice medicine I taught
medicine and Psychiatry for years hear
words that never came out of my mouth
what do you think the CDC would say
about that what is it what's the FDA Say
Never Ever Ever they have nothing to do
with the practice of medicine at all
yeah except they CDC provides some
information for us so we can scroll
through some of the data the FDA
determines what companies can do in
terms of how they bring things to Market
what we do with those things totally up
to us as practitioners and also the fact
that everyone's so defensive is exactly
what's making me want to ask more
questions yeah me too it's so funny I
have that same exact impulse which is
that's why I wanted to interview those
people I'm like that guy was the
chairman Department Immunology he was
decorated by all the medical students
for 20 years and he's an asshole I want
to talk to him if he was like yeah
there's probably some side effects I
mean I'm sure there are I'd be like oh
okay like he's or we don't know yet I
was like there absolutely weren't I'm
like now this is fishy this is fishy
right to be that doc protest too much
well especially in biology everything's
everything takes so long to arrive at a
consensus of what we are sure of biology
is a very complex thing to me those
people should be saying how could we
possibly know yet yeah and if they were
saying that I'd be like okay yeah I I
don't need to I think it's the right
thing to do it's the best we can do
right now you're getting emotional you
have some kind of weird skin in the game
and this doesn't feel objective I agree
with you you know and then if I say you
know why are 17 year olds having heart
attacks and people like they've always
had heart attacks in basketball games in
high schools you're just noticing it now
I know yes you're just noticing it we're
just reporting it now if you didn't by
the way some data came out this morning
Actuarial data that shows it is
happening and it is new and it's not
good
this morning
U.S Actuarial data
and look I'm the first person by the way
it might be one in a zillion but it's
not good I'm the first person that would
go okay let's play Devil's Advocate to
that yeah it could be stress from the
pandemic it could be post covet
infection yep that's the other thing
that but because I've been saying from
the beginning it could be a vaccine it
could be covid it could be coveted plus
vaccine it could be both of them could
be if you had both that may be the one
thing that'll do but you're not even
allowed to ask any questions that's what
I'm saying it's crazy it could be we'll
find out later it was cell phones that
that person flu airplanes yeah this
person had it would live near a lead
plant this person lived on a uranium
like we can't figure it out if we don't
ask the question but we don't know yet
and the fact that no one can say that
definitively it's not this that's what's
making me feel spooked you should be
the last seven episodes of your podcast
has been really really wild oh
interesting like we know that Coca-Cola
is bad for you I can say it and no one
loses their minds right you know what I
mean right we know McDonald's is not
good for you but there probably was a
time if you said that Campbell
cigarettes were not good people would
have been like well my doctor recommends
it or when my wife's pregnant my wife's
smoking camels and this will always be
true
and how could it not be like what are
you talking about like the fact that the
ability it's a lack of humility or some
kind of Stockholm syndrome there's that
too well that's the mass formation thing
but but we need a lot more humility but
this but but by the way you've written
into that too is why do you feel it's
your business what one doctor does with
one patient that's none of your fucking
business because if you don't back that
person it could kill my grandmother no
they have some kind of that's not true
though we know that's not true now but
when people went nutty over Joe Rogan's
doctor doing what he did I was like yeah
why is it that's between I told Joe I
said that's two of you and by the way
what he did for you is very interesting
and there were things he did that was
way outlying yeah then of course because
people don't know enough to know that
those were outlying moves they didn't
even notice those yeah they took the I
word they went at that like yeah horse
Pace thing meantime he's getting uh NAD
infusions like oh that's that's unusual
that's interesting white did it help uh
let's talk about it no they have to have
an opinion about this one thing it's
like interesting because like I guess
this is kind of the first time in
history that we could all hear
everybody's watercolor conversations
about someone so it's like yes I'm sure
when Richard Pryor talked about beating
his wife and stuff there were dinner
parties and people the office were like
this guy this guy this guy we just
didn't have a bunch of proof of it you
know so maybe we're just seeing more of
the that and maybe the fact that a whole
generation essentially been reared on
that instrument they feel they have to
intervene or to have an opinion or with
some of their identities involved with
what's going on out there in the world
which is not healthy it's interesting
because if if you know I have a couple
girlfriends that after they got boosted
they or maybe it was I don't remember
after they got the initial or because
they had their periods oh yeah that's
happening just kept having them yeah
very true and my guess is if I were to
ask them or when during the time
you're about to get the shot you will
not get covid and you will not spread it
to any family members or any vulnerable
people but you're gonna have your period
first 12 months straight yeah they'd
probably be like all right I'll do it
you know what I mean that's how scary
scared everyone was well and maybe if it
worked the way it was supposed to work
it would have been worth that was great
you know I just talked to Naomi wolf you
know she is yeah dude I got into what I
do because of the beauty myth you should
bring her in to talk to her she's
wonderful to not be able to hold it
together but she's so great she's so
cute I'm gonna try to figure out a way
to take you guys to dinner that book
like formed me as a thinker yeah she she
was she's so bright and she started
talking about this observation and I was
extremely dismissive I was like Naomi
you sneeze it around a woman their
periods go off women in the 40s bragging
they're not menopausal you're just
trying to say you don't you're having
your period I'm just like doesn't really
mean anything so come on let's not make
too much of it women's periods to be
fair are incredibly around well now we
are finding microcloths in the uterus
for finding Spike protein in the ovaries
and in the uterine lining and I and I
heard all that many women that calcified
placentas may or may not be significant
but I ended up publicly apologizing to
her I said I am so sorry I was
dismissive I shouldn't have been I shoot
much more open-minded I should be
listening and we don't know these things
yet and maybe it's nothing true name is
nothing but and then the woman named
Vicki male who is very very pro-vaccine
uh during pregnancy particularly uh what
I saw her report that she put out
yesterday would show that oh yes uh both
the vaccine does cause irregular periods
for one cycle I was like well that's
false because I've definitely seen it
for six Cycles routinely routinely so
now again you start wondering what's
wrong with the literature why is it just
one cycle with that essentially Almost
Never ever happens it's always like
sustained problems like your friends and
also most women aren't reporting this
most women don't have health insurance
most women aren't part of these studies
too so there's also there's so much we
don't know can I ask one thing about the
the just preservation of this thing
mercury in general is a big a lot of
people are talking about it right now
whether it's it's in fish it's in
fillings when you take out your feelings
and the Mercury is really nuts or the
Apple Mercury it's not really in the
vaccine then then people flipped over to
aluminum I'm like I don't know because
you know I I worked in a time when
people use aluminum levels used to go
Sky High if they were in kidney dialysis
because of the way we right they would
you would get actually something called
Denver dialysis center they get so much
aluminum in their blood that they would
get intoxicated from the aluminum and
they never had any Adverse Events I
never saw anything happen from the
aluminum so I I've always been very
skeptical of that stuff so that's me
like faster you're just all over a fish
I mean Mercury is not good for you I
mean it's not something I would welcome
into my system heavy metals and I go
good but it's like remember when Jeremy
Piven like left that play because of
mercury poisoning or something you know
what Howard Stern said he got some
Mercury issues too and and I'm sure it
happens but
that's a lot of mercury you'd have to be
uh deep throat in a lot and you stop and
the things resolved that's like when
kings used to get gout if you're eating
so much sushi that you have mercury or
probably have too much money or yes yes
can I do just speed round and then I'll
get you out of here Mt fkr Gene where
some people can foliate folic acid some
people can foliate that's a real thing
yeah and so do I if you're pregnant need
to take folic acid do you need to get
tested for it
uh I'm not seeing data that separates
out that population from the folate need
generally but uh folic acid is a really
important supplement of pregnancy for
everybody can't some people foliate B12
and some people can't so you would want
to get tested for that to make sure you
need to take B12 or foliated B12 I think
a lot of people I know that are trying
to pound B12 and like make sure you can
foliate it first yes correct okay but
you know we used to always say just
always get folate with B12 you know okay
just a blood type diet zero zero I don't
see anything in that zero I I will try
it okay because look just paying
attention to your diet yes has dramatic
effects so whatever I'm really I'm
serious about this just eating
consciously has a dramatic effect on on
your health so please if you want to
follow uh anything follow it
um be conscious
sunscreens in cancer I know I I I I I I
don't have an opinion yet okay I've been
watching that I'm worried about it
there's something there I don't know
what it is yet it always did feel weird
to me that like putting something on
your face stopped the sun this has got
to have some kind of chemicals yes yes
and but is it worse than the sun that's
the question right
using so much sunscreen I'm a vampire
that I had a vitamin D deficiency oh no
you know too crazy that's an important
supplement vitamin D very important I
guess I'm ready to be a hat lady
I'm about to be a hat lady any because
of what you worked um is so much in
having so much experience in mood
disorder stuff like that
um how do you feel about lithium these
days
well you're talking about mood
instability right mood you know
bipolarity classically uh lithium you
know it's a funny drug it's a it's a
salt it's not a big deal it has some
kidney effects
and it can you gotta watch it it has to
be in certain values it's I've never
thought of it as a good for a while
there they were adding it to
antidepressants to enhance the effect of
antidepressants never saw a dramatic
effect from that I I always worried
about bipolar patients on lithium
because the the anti-seizure meds the
Lamictal and the Depakote are so much
better I mean bipolarity is really kind
of a seizure phenomenon it's like a
kindling that gets going and then it's a
fire and you got to put the fire out
anti-seizure meds work beautifully for
that
um I had a lot of success with 5-HTP
it's good it's just right and whether
it's placebo effect no no that makes
sense to have some effect do you ever I
mean obviously no but I always like joke
that I want to open a medical practice
it's just Placebo it's just sugar pills
I have no objection with Placebo if it
makes people feel better it's so
effective it seems like I was prescribed
five milligrams of long release Adderall
to sleep to sleep yeah weird right
because if you if you're taking out if
you actually have added you down calms
you down and then I had I was prescribed
10 milligrams Prozac and found out later
that it was like a placebo dose for kids
but it really worked yeah well I but
that but that's a pharmaceutical agent
that's more than a placebo right even
you know anything pharmacological is
extra physiological right it's it's
already taking your system and tweaking
it by the way people have such a weird
feeling about doctors prescribing I I
you know look as a physician we have two
things basically we do we cut and we
prescribe right and that's it yeah
that's all we can do other than that we
can give you our knowledge and education
and we can just send you a physical
therapist so we can send you to a
psychotherapist things like that where
they do their thing with their knowledge
but as clinicians we're essentially just
prescribing we're trying to change the
biology in a positive direction or deal
with the anatomy with a knife trying to
change that in a positive direction
it's all we got I'm going to ask your
protocol in a second but is there
anything because I feel like you know uh
I think there's such a reason that you
get along so well with Comedians and
have so many comedians around you is I
think you know we tend to see things
coming down the bend yes you do I love
that you're watching stuff you're seeing
patterns and you you're penetrating
things but we're kind of because of
whatever trauma we come from we always
had to be 10 steps ahead we always had
to anticipate danger we always had to be
hyper Vigilant or kind of you know so
we're always sort of thinking or maybe
we just have a lot of time on our hands
and we're thinking about the future and
this is going to be a problem like we
were talking about censorship and all
this stuff four or five years ago
everyone thinks we're crazy and we're
paranoid but we're always trying to
sound the arms kind of what we do is
this is coming this is coming yes
whether people listen or not and I think
that you know you're someone that sees
things before everyone else is going to
see it it's not that Clairvoyant I know
what you're talking about but I mean
you're the one that's seen I see them
when they start yeah
it's going I see it and I have an
opinion about it because I I know I've
seen so much I practiced medicine so
long I just know what's you what when
things are out of line and when your
boots on the ground of you know seeing
what's coming down the pike like what do
you feel like right now you're kind of
like uh I don't have enough information
yet to say this is going to be a big
problem in 10 years you know whether
it's
um you know uh you know intermittent
fasting I know people there's mixed
reviews on whether that's you know super
effective or not if it's effective for
you none of my business stress your body
out Do It
um I was anorexic for like 15 years so I
think I hopefully got the benefits um
but is there anything you look to that's
like oh this is
I got my eye on this well I
you know vision loss from computer you
know use porn in its effect I'm worried
about that I I would on young people I
just we just don't know what what is
that gonna play out guinea pigs I I
worry about the average age of kids
losing their virginity is going up right
but the average age of porn exposure is
going down yeah and and maybe that's
what's maybe people are freaked out like
oh that's not me I don't want to be part
of that maybe they can traumatize by
looking at it there's somebody that's
interesting hypothesizes some of the
gender stuff is related to that like
well I'm not must not be a woman or I
must not be a man I don't like any of
that stuff that's what I have to do I'm
out right it's like that must not be me
I must be maybe or maybe they're
traumatized I don't want it to be me I I
I don't know well this stuff needs to be
kind of worked out yeah whoa that's
mind-blowing if it's if it's a I don't
know if that's a thing or not literally
that's the category now mind blowing
yeah
it's a new porn category when it got
into like step mother and step brother
like which I guess isn't technically
incest MILF porn seems Progressive like
MILF porn being number one seems like
you like that really promising
um but when it starts getting into like
the normalization of this like sex with
Step Brothers and step mothers I'm like
I don't know guys yeah what's that all
about I don't know and but I do there is
something I've heard about just recently
that has got on my radar that I've been
concerned about
so I've noticed that young males are
really not good in their relational
situations they're either afraid of
women they're afraid of being seen as
toxically masculine they wouldn't dare
offer a woman a drink when they're
relating to them or having you know
dating whatever they are uh they're
they're freaked out and scared and they
are not developing the normal milestones
and skill sets for dating and forming
relationships and women are mistreating
them so you say my robot does a market
for my robot young men are going to
porno to uh prostitutes and I and all
those years during a level line I never
heard that now all of a sudden it's it's
on my radar they're going to prostitutes
and once they go they keep going
and it's concerning I mean I see why
there's safety in transactional sex
these days where people are worried I'm
gonna send the wrong text or I'm going
to read the signals wrong
or toxic or whatever which is tricky
because by the way then they don't
develop the skills they need to properly
navigate those things and I'm I'm look
I'm it's actually you're making a lot of
bells go off because I the last couple
guys I've dated are like very or younger
and they are also moving to older weight
am I a prostitute um no no that's the
other thing they're doing moving to
older women that they know they can't
hurt me I don't know I can't remember my
Twitter password I'm not gonna accuse
you of anything I don't even know how
right and not because you're older but
because you're not part of their peer
age who are so hyper Vigilant about all
this stuff yeah and the stakes are so
high of like am I gonna misread these
signals and you know and then girls are
going choke me hit me spank me and it's
like ah is this a trap and then a girl
gets her heart broken and then you know
I have no idea what kind of dumb stuff I
would have done in my teens and early
20s after getting my heart broken if I
had Twitter or some way to blast a guy
that broke my heart oh I have no idea
what would have happened with like the
fact I was not in a program yet I was
like a burn it all down like that's a
very powerful Insight uh and and I I
hope a women who have hear her saying
that will write and tell you their story
stories and interact with you about that
don't just do something sit there like
decide like if you're going to make a
decision about something like that that
that's that permanent that's perfect
they're like we're gonna perceived it a
certain way too and it's going to affect
your life forever their life forever
like I'm not saying sit on something
illegal that happened but decide if you
want this to be your number one Google
search for the rest of your life right
you know that's a very powerful insight
and It's tricky because there's a lot of
yeah that was bad sex that's not legal
yeah I asked for something I didn't get
it he that was transaction or just was
uncomfortable I didn't like it whatever
it was it was just talking to a comic
about this last night and about like
sort of I've done it too where I wanted
it so badly to be like I don't need
anything serious I don't want anything
serious I can just sleep around I'm not
gonna get attached to this person here I
am on his Facebook page attached to this
person you know so we don't know what
our neurochemicals are gonna do we don't
know how we're gonna behave when we're
you know heartbroken and and admit it to
yourself when you do a real feeling my
day we just drive by their house
we weren't sending Tweets and ruining
their life you know so I'm really
horrified and embarrassed by some of the
things that I did under the influence of
fear and grief and heartbreak in my
early 20s and you know so who knows do
you have OCD features too a little bit
me yeah okay what because because I have
that too I have that also and that and
that drives some of that kind of
obsessional stuff yes absolutely you
know so especially when you're younger
yeah yeah and I mean it's like cutting I
mean you know it's really like how do I
you know at least having no idea how to
self-soothe having no idea you know what
I'm owed and then you're talking to your
girlfriends you're like he shouldn't
have done that and he shouldn't have
said that and then I see him with some
girl and now all of a sudden
I was
don't want to take responsibility for
my part in it or we do wild stuff when
we're hurt I'm like you know
wild stuff to try to sell people hurt
people that's the famous whole statement
tweet about people to be hurtful exactly
final thing your can I ask you you have
more energy than most people I know
you're now into self can I just ask what
you're doing the supplement yes does one
of the so okay so I'm just 65 in a
couple of weeks that's crazy yeah isn't
that crazy and uh
so I mean I you had to remember I
practiced medicine for 30 years before I
was doing a lot of TV and radio and
stuff and um
are you okay I just you look so good
sorry very well preserved for someone
that has slept so little and had to take
on so many I'm sleeping again now I'm
sleeping I'm trying to pay attention to
that so
um I've always been exerciser always
always and as I told you we were talking
about my friend Peter attia and he we
were talking about longevity and finally
when I was bugging him about a lot of
different ideas and he finally turned to
me and went vigorous exercise that's the
one thing for sure and uh lately I've
been being part of this organization
called V shred where they put me on a
diet an exercise program and it's really
been great I can completely sign off on
it because it's like having a trainer
but it's just a video trainer kind of
thing I take in terms of supplements
that I take I take
um something called true niagen which is
an NAD
I've talked to their scientists I became
convinced some time ago that there's
something to that and as you know Rogan
and Segura and those guys are getting
NAD infusions which is a much more
powerful way to play basketball as much
as a girl does you're gonna have to make
your bones that was the craziest thing
ever it still makes no sense
okay so I take I take two nitrogen I'm
also on blood pressure medicine and
cholesterol medicine and that kind of
stuff and I prostate cancer you know and
I processed it out 12 years ago and I've
had radiation and I'm yeah yeah it's all
part of aging if you gotta get a cancer
that's a good one to get get ahead of it
yeah well it's just not a it's a slow
one
um okay so I take uh the Nadia to the
nicotine I might rob aside you do the
NAD the nmn also I don't I did for a
while and um I just I'm convinced I feel
like the entity is much more direct to
the biology I take but I do take nastil
cysteine which is a way to try to raise
glutathione which does like antioxidants
but you wouldn't take glutathione Direct
it doesn't get in doesn't get where it's
supposed to go if somebody could
convince me it was getting where it
needed to go I would uh and uh hmb
recently has come out as something that
might be good for our brains and things
so I just started that uh let me think
is there anything oh I take fish oils I
take I particularly uh DHA all right
same same idea same idea again exactly
what you should be doing there I just
try to stay with high quality fish oils
that's my thing I take a vitamin D with
K2 okay I do that uh let me see is there
anything else I'm doing that's kind of
goofy
I take our Reds for the eye I have a
little macular degeneration from all the
years of UV exposure as a lifeguard when
I was a kid
um and I think minerals are important I
think mineral supplementation again this
is for older this guy's I'm in my 60s
yeah is that for you it's for guys like
me I mean the NAD thing might be I
started when I was probably 45.
Resveratrol
maybe I have no objection to it I don't
do it right I did it for a while I just
I'm not sure magnesium aren't we all
pretty deficient yes I take magnesium
yep and it takes molybdenum and selenium
and a bunch of other you know Trace
elements right metformin
it really looks good like I said I was
born I was on it I mean I just had to go
off because of it matched gestational
diabetes but I felt like I felt like my
skin was better and I had so much more
energy is that PCO or anything it'd be a
polycystic ovaries no because it's
really good for that but but I'm not
accusing you I mean okay what does that
means
it's a really common thing for women
um I I was actually bugging Peter about
metformin when he turned to me and said
vigorous exercise so that's what I like
and I like saying vigorous exercise
because we all know we're supposed to
exercise but I mean I like the
explanation of like the biological basis
for why carrying heavy things doing
vigorous exercise it tells this is like
the dumb way of saying it and please
correct me of like telling your DNA
you're still valuable to the tribe like
stay young like you know use this thing
use that as much as you can learn new
languages things like that but there was
something else I was doing oh I also
really been trying to limit
carbohydrates we had a little talk about
that yeah I could never get my HDL up
and drop my triglyceride down until I
cut out carbohydrate
do you remember the old food pyramid oh
my God
[Laughter]
[Music]
food pyramid was Bonkers well they came
up with some new ones it was even
equally as bad look bureaucrats do not
know how to make medical recommendations
like Wonder Bread like food pyramid
brought to you by Wonder Bread he's in
12 ways brought to you by Pillsbury like
yeah yeah well this is this is a I think
General
skepticism towards things that are being
advertised or marketed to you is a very
proper way to to go any postpartum
depression tips there's a new medication
looks really good really yeah you have
to take an IV at first I've been reading
a lot about it lately and it's like wow
I think this it's a it's a Gaba medicine
okay so it's not a SSRI any of those
things and man the data looks good now
I've only seen a couple papers not a lot
of data yet but but there is something
now that I think that's going to be a a
you know a potential option for women
the thing that the dreaded complication
postpartum is postpartum psychosis
because those are wild the key to
handling postpartum psychosis is to just
have had pre-partum psychosis
some of the wildest psychosis I've ever
seen have been been postpartum psychosis
like when you hear about women drowning
their babies and stuff like that
I mean a lot of it is exhaustion and
sleep deprivation right it only makes
things worse but it's these massive
shifts in your biology massive massive
massive you have to kind of prepare for
it and then you have stress and a baby
and no sleep handle these things all at
once okay I really hope my night nurse
doesn't have postpartum
get Manpower get help I'm getting I'm
getting do not be embarrassed about that
no triplets you know that is so wild
it's beyond and we were just like
whenever other people have multiples I
just think Manpower just get help yep
don't be embarrassed yep yep yep you
have to survive I'm gonna have a Night
Nurse who will be there to survive
you've got to survive and by the way if
you're so tired that you can't be
available for the child or you're having
fantasies of killing the child which
also are normal yeah because I do get
intrusive thoughts sometimes when I'm
holding someone else's baby I'm like
what if I just drop this baby and I
think and it seems like oh that probably
served a purpose there's a biological
basis for that like to worry about
something like that but hopefully when
it's my cat it won't be that no that's
your OCD great news it's just my OCD
thank you so much I love spending time
with you yeah so this was really fun
let's do it again and again long overdue
all right don't ride elephants I own
these awkwardly love you guys
[Music]
foreign